[音楽]
me
平和ねっ
皆さん聞こえますかすごいうちわ持ってくださって受けたわけじゃなくなるんですけど
はいじゃあ始めたいと思います
皆さんはあの私たちが生きる時代というものをちょっと考えたことがあるでしょうか
私たちは企画や組織を立ち上げることのハードルが低くなった時代に生きていると思い
ます
ただその代わりに継続することが難しくいつも間にか終わってしまったり
またまた悲しい終わりを迎えるということも多いのではないでしょうか
初ちょっと皆さんに聞きたいことがあるので該当するのと思う方は手を挙げてください
一つ目は比較や組織を一度でもいいのでタッチあげたことがあるよと言う方始めたこと
があるというかた手を挙げてください
ちょっと周りを見ていただくと分かるんですが約89割ぐらいの方が笑顔でビールと
思いますありがとうございます
そしてもう一つ
比較や組織から離れたり終わるときに100%ポジティブに終わりを迎えたことがある
という片手を上げてみてください
[音楽]
もう一度ちょっと周りを見てみてくださいね
今1割もしくは2割の方しか手を挙げていません
ありがとうございます
実は私はこの同じ質問を twitter のフォロワーの方だったり友人たちにも
聞いてみたんですがやはり一つ目は9割から8割ぐらいの人が立ち上げたことがある
よってを挙げたんですが
2割1回ぐらいの人が100%ポジティブに終わりを迎えたことがあると決断をあの
結論に至りました
実際に私はどうかというと観ていただければわかるんですが
23歳の頃に立ち上げ30歳になる今まで運営してきた非営利団体を閉じるということ
を最近決断しました
20代のほとんどをこの団体に費やしてきたので
ちょっと言ってみると普通の女の子に戻る
アイドルのような気分でいます
いい感じの9章ありがとうございます
ちなみに皆さんは私たちのようにこのどのようにを得る各話し合いはした経験はあり
ますか
さっきのアイドルの子アイドルを事例に出すとだいたいそのアイドルもファンがつか
なかったり共感を得られずいつのまにか聴いてしまっている人がいたりだとか
時に女優になったり起業家になったりとか
ポジティブな転身してそうに見えますがそのほとんどは自分の意思に反して自分の
チーム法
雷や組織の代表が辞めたり離れることを決断していることが多いのではないでしょうか
そして果たしてそれらの中に100%ポジティブかつ社会的にも有益な思いがあったと
いえるでしょうか
私たちは
始めるときにはすごくパワー抑えて華々しくスタートするんですがいつのまにか終わっ
てしまったりそして
戦略的に終えるということができずにいる人たちそして団体が多くいると思います
なぜなら私たちはこの終わるということをどこか悲しい感じがしてしまったり
ネガティブなイメージだったりして考えることや話し合うことよさっきできたのでは
ないでしょうか
でも本当に割ることは悲しいことでしょうかそしてネガティブにしかなり得ないことな
んでしょうか
私が運営してきた非営利団体はこのどのようにを得るかという話し合いはもともとの
目的を達成するために
どのようにその目的を達成するのかそしてどうやったら実現できるのか
という前向きかつポジティブの話し合いの中で出た結論であり今回のエディックスの
テーマである
discover
明日アイディアですそれがこちら
有機的解散と発展的現象です
これは私のような社会起業家だけでなくさきほど手を挙げた
皆さんそしてこれからの時代に何か残しておきたい人たちにとって有益なアイディアで
あると言えると思います
インターネット私たちはこのインターネットで様々なもののハードルを下げてきました
例えば何かモノをつくった時には店舗を設営して売らなければならそうながならなそう
だった時代だったりだとか
趣味は趣味のまま止め起業するにも社会人経験があるって
ドナないとだめそうだったりとか情報もどこにあるか分からなくてどうしたらいいか
わからないという理由でチャレンジできない人が多いくいた時代があったと思います
ただ今私たちが生きる時代は天保なんてもとなくともオンラインからスタートすれば
いいし守備も youtube だったり facebook とか twitter
で言葉に表すことでお金を儲けられる時代になってきたり
私たちの友達でもこの中高生で起業する子たちなんて山のように入って社会線ケーキ
ので一切ない子たちでも起業できるようになってきました
そして大体の情報はググればすぐ出てくるし
facebook にこんな情報知ってるってポストすれば多くの人たち友達たちが
あっ
それを知ってるよーここに載ってるよと教えてくれるそんなやりとりができるような
時代に生きていると思います
そして私の想いしてきた団体はどうかというと私たちのメンバーなんですが
えっ
全国類930名のメンバーが介在しているんですが本当に今まで会ったこともない子
たちから sns を通してこの断崖入りたいと手を挙げてくれて面談もすべてオン
ラインで完結しすべてのミーティングや議事録メモはオンラインネット上にアップする
ことで
誰でもどこからでもアクセスできるようにすることによって初期費用初めに必要なお金
だったり経験が入らないままチャレンジできるようになりました
そして
これが真インターネットが作ったハードルが下がった時期に立ち上げた
組織のあり方だったりこういうパターンもあるかなと思うんですが
まあ時として私はこの起業して6年間の中で諸先輩方からやや
そんな簡単に立ち上げたって成功するわけがない
せいか上がるわけないよと言われてきたのでいやでもそれでも上がる時代は来ている
なぁと思ったからこそ少しちょっと事例をお伝えしたい事例というか
私たちは成果ですねお伝えしたいと思います
私は23才の頃に立ち上げ30歳になる今まで運営してきてら約6年間活動してきたん
ですがここにある通り
20以上の商品を開発してきたりだとか80社以上の企業行政学校と連携し更にはその
プロダクト商品であったり自分たちが効く
失くしたものが70市上村以上に広まりました
そしてこの考え方やあり方を参考にしたいとアジア太平洋を9カ国のリーダーたちが
日本に来日して来てくれ
私たちにどうしたらいいかという質問をしに来てくれるほどにもなりました
これが私たちの様々なものがハードルが下がった時代のあり方なのではないでしょうか
ただ一方で皆さんにお伝えしなければならないのはポジティブなことばかりではないと
いうことです
地方の人が来ない観光地だったりだとか
いないでの以内で同文化頭だ入社希望者のいない中小企業もそうだと思います立ち上げ
たはいうものの継続することが難しくそして
終わるという選択を取りきれていないところが山ほどあるということを皆さんも
分かってきているのではないかなと思います
[音楽]
実際に先ほど自治体等仕事をさせていただいているということちょっとお伝えしたん
ですが多くの自治体から似たようなことを私言われていましてその言葉もちょっと皆
さんにバラしちゃいたいなと思うんですがそれがこちらです
読み上げますね
五重天井してほしい観光客増やしたい
地域のリソースを活用してほしい伝統文化を継承したい
地域のいいところを pr してほしいとこんなに思い出詰まった方々に
市4町村だけじゃなく本当に書く際の乳他
100番の自治体の方々にこのような質問と依頼をされてきました
もちろん尊くて素晴らしいなと思うんですが
よく見てもらうと分かるんですがやっぱりこの背景には継続すること発展することこそ
がすばらしいという概念や思い込みが兄隠れするなと思いませんか
私は継続すること発展することはあくまで選択肢の一つであるべきでそこが本質なので
はないと思います
私たちはこの継続し発展したその先に何を成し遂げたいかとか
何を実現したいかが放湿なのではないでしょうか
そこがすれ違っている継続することが目的になってしまっているような組織や
プロジェクトが山のようにあるように感じました
ここで少し半分ぐらいの方が驚愕生産だと聞いているので今はちょっと企業とか自治体
の話が多くなってしまったので
ライフライフスタイルというか日常生活の中でもこういうことが起きるということを
少し紹介します
完全なる独断と偏見でトップする決めました
始めたはいいものの継続も終わるのも難しい top 3
はっはっは
ありがとうございますちょっと無理やりがありましたねねはい完全なる独断偏見なん
ですが
1習い事2敗3ダイエット本当にちょっと皆さんな付いてたり笑っている方要注意です
からねあの始めたはいいもののやっぱり金属難しくってしかも終わる時に例えば皆さん
延々と書けへんしたことがある方が多いと思うんですけどやっぱり終わる時に自然消滅
してしまったりポジティブにお別れするなんてことがありましたか
やはり立ち上げたお芋の継続が難しくを得るのが難しいことは日常生活の中でも
たくさんあります
ただ私はどんなことがあっても時代や環境や人のせいにしないと決めています
これまで出した事例すべてが動か時代や環境他人のせいにして自分たちは頑張っている
んだとしている連戦だったりだとか
言い方が多かったなぁと私は思いました
なので私はやや少しじゃなくて自分たちが元々立ち上げた時の目的に対する責任感だっ
たりどうしてそこまで達成したいのか実現したいのかという思いの死骸がここに出て
いるのではないかと思います
ここで皆さん中で少しずつ終わり方とか終わる事に興味が出始めたかなと
目線とか頷き具合で感じたのでここで終わり方のパターンをご紹介したいと思います
こちらスタンフォードソーシャルイノベーションレビューでだしている組織の終わり方
のグラフになります
左から始めスタートして継続発展していったこの青フライングな終わり方のパターンに
当たるんですが上から一番上が継続発展という意味で今までの事例を出したものが求め
ていた計測することを発見することなんですが他にも自治体に受け渡したり起業2倍
一周させると入れ方があったりオープンソースという誰でもアクセスでき
可変できるようにするという手法もあればこの一番下はもともとの目的を達成すると
いう終わり方があります
ただ私6年間起業していろんな企業家だったりだとかプロジェクト企画を見てきたん
ですがそれでもこの選択を考えている組織は動くわずかでさらには選択に至る前に自然
消滅してしまったり
がむしゃらに続けることだけを考えてもともとの目的を忘れし忘れてし
待っている組織が多かったなと思います
そこで私たちはじゃあいくつかのパターンを試してみようと私の組織でも終わり方の
パターン試してみたんですがどれもしっくりこなかったんですね
なので私たちは自分らしい終わり方とはなんぞや
同組織を破るべきかどうあるべきかうと話し合いの中で出たアイデアが有機的解散と
発展できる
これは
1864年にハーバードスペンサーという方が作った造語
survival of the fish ですと日本語で言うと適者生存6という
考え方があります
聞いたことがある方もいらっしゃるかなと思うんですが変化していく流れの中で
適したものが残っていくという考え方です
この考えを用いて私たちは今までワープ言う御家流私たちがどうありたい方は何を
成し遂げたいかという主体を自分たちに持ってきたんですが
いやいや私たちは大きな流れの一部であるんだと捉えた時に
この大きな流れは振り for our ジュディ私たちはどんな正解を実現したいの
かとかどんな未来を実現したいのかいう中でじゃあ私たちはどうあるべきなのかという
いわば東洋の一元論のような考え方を持つようになり
4ヤシ座を高め自分たち
がどうあるべきかを考えました
そうしたときにより良い世の中だったり実現したいことを考えた時
私たちだけじゃなくて
一人が頑張る100%ポジティブな人たちが一つだけあるんじゃなくて
より多くのチャレンジャーが増えて行ったほうがこの大きな流れを作り出し実現できる
のではないかそして加速できるのではないかと考えました
そこで私たちはこの6年間培った
樹脂鬼屋敷情報人脈すべてを分かりやすくまとめ
継承する相手を公募し引き継ぎ私たちは立ち去るということを決断しました
もちろんここに居続けるということも選択肢としてあったんですがやはり私たちが入る
ことによってこの流れのボトルネックになってしまったり
私たちがこの流れを
低速させてしまうのではないかと思ったので私たちは抜けることによってこの作りたい
未来を実現するということを決断しています
今までであればネガティブな解散は奥的達成のための会派へ
そして目的のない伝承は時代
氷塊を加速するための伝承会
私たちはそのために有機的解散と発展的伝承という今までにはあまりなかった
解散終わり方を実現したいと思っています
いわばもともと同じ主持飛び立つタンポポの綿毛のように
そして同じ星だったのが宇宙で爆発したくさんの星になって輝く
宇宙のように私たちはこれを実現したいと
皆さんは皆さんの関わる組織やプロジェクトをどのようにを得ますか
そして皆さんはこれからの変化し行く時代に何を残していきたいです
[拍手]